>>commentator: Hi all. Welcome to Authors@Google
in New York. And we're here to welcome Amanda
Pressner and Holly Corbett, two of the three
lost girls.
We sent out information about it. They have
a website and now they have a book and it's
soon to be made into an ABC show next fall,
I think it is by Jerry Bruckheimer. So we're
really happy to welcome them-them here.
And also one other note, there's a third lost
girl, Jenn, but she is actually I think working
with the Food Network on a shoot so she couldn't
be here today. But, so there's three, but
we're happy to have two of them.
So the three of these wonderful women in 2006
basically paused their jobs as they described
to me earlier and they wanted to travel the
world for a year. And so this book is just
a memoir of them traveling the world and what
it was like to kind of let go of their life
in New York and jobs, boyfriends, family,
and travel the world.
So welcome to them. And then Lee is gonna,
they're gonna read a little bit from the-the
memoir and then Lee's gonna moderate some
questions.
And feel free once we open it up to answer
questions at the mike. And please join me
in welcoming them to Google.
[applause]
>>Lee: Well thank you guys for coming.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah, thanks for having us
here. We're really excited to be here at Google.
We kind of wrote up some things to say, but
we're pretty much just gonna ad lib so --
>>Lee: We can have people if you wanna kind
of come like in from the sides and the back
row. I know you're gonna be on the computer
and that's kind of --
>>Amanda Pressner Come on in. Snuggle in.
[laughs]
>>Lee: people are working through their lunch
but --
>>Holly Corbett: Sounds great – you guys
can bring your computer.
>>Lee: And probably later when we do questions
it might be easier just to pass the microphones
around so you don't have to stand up, if that's
cool. It would be easier to pass 'em if we're
a little bit more tighter knit, but --
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah, well just to give you
a little bit of background information about
us. I'm Holly. This is Amanda, and Jenn is
away working today so she couldn't be here.
But it was about four years ago, three and
a half or four years ago that the three of
us were working in media in New York. Amanda
and I were at magazines and Jenn was in television.
And we were working a lot of hours and it
wasn't that we were unhappy with our jobs;
we loved our jobs; we'd worked really hard
to get there and-and to be working in magazines,
but we kinda started to feel like there was
more to life than sitting at our cubicle every
day.
And so as the months ticked by we kind of,
we started to get more baby shower announcements
and wedding invites and all this stuff ?
>>Lee: [chuckles]
>>Holly Corbett: and we were getting to be
in our late 20's and we just started to feel
some pressure to hit certain milestones. Like
find our soul mate, buy a home, have our kids,
and-and get a big promotion at work.
All of the time we were in our mid to early
30's so we just kind of started to-to feel
that way and like time was moving really,
really fast.
So it wasn't until we actually got away from
work; we got to take a 10 day vacation which
was really rare. Somehow the three of us managed
to do it. And we went to Argentina.
And it was when we weren't on autopilot anymore,
when we had more space and time for reflection,
that we started to ask ourselves some really
important questions.
Wi-with deadlines hanging over our heads we
didn't really have a lot of time to think
about what direction we were heading in life.
So we started to ask, "Are the jobs that we're
at really the things that we wanna be doing?
What were we doing to give back? Were we in
the right city, in the right relationships?"
And so Amanda kind of threw out this idea
like, "What if we traveled for a year and
took a year long vacation?"
So after that, we never really thought it
would happen, but the three of us kind of
decided that, "Yes, this is something that
we wanna do," because we-we wanna stop living
on automatic pilot; we wanna get some space
and time for reflection. And for us travel
was a really good way to do that.
So --
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
So I didn't think when I suggested taking,
it's like a vacation fantasy you're-you're
away for a week, you've escaped the office.
We managed to have 10 days of escape and we
didn't bring our computers or BlackBerrys
or anything.
And it was really like the most meaningful
10 days of my life and I was with these two
really great women. And when I threw out the
idea to travel around the world for a year,
I kind of never really considered that either
one of them would do it.
But we all encountered these challenges in
our lives and for me it was, I, of the three
of us I was definitely the most workaholic
type. I was at the office, I was working at
a magazine which is where I met Holly and
I was putting in a ton of hours thinking,
"At least this is like one guaranteed thing
in my life. That if I work really, really
hard, I'll get promoted and I'll keep moving
up the ladder."
But I remember coming back from jury duty
one day and finding out that not only did
I not get this big promotion that I'd been
slaving away to get, I'd been put on probation
because I hadn't come into the office after
jury duty, that I'm like, "What the hell am
I doing? I've-I've gotta change something."
And I went back to Jenn and Holly and said,
"Were you really serious about taking this
trip?"
And because of things they were going through
in their lives, their relationships that might
not have been working out or just this sincere
desire to see more of the world, we all were
like, "Let's do it."
And we planned for 18 months. We saved; none
of us had a ton of money saved up, but we
worked hard. Holly got a-a job writing a column
for a small magazine and on June 20th, 2010
or 2006 actually, [laughs] we-we left and
we did this year around the world.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: And-and then as far as,
as far as the Lost Girls name which you'll
see at the title of the book, we named ourselves
that kind of in jest because we really felt
lost about our futures.
And we knew from talking to a lot of other
young men and women that we really weren't
the only ones that felt that way and for us
the trip was about kind of pushing the pause
button on-on the lives that we had to really
reflect and figure out what made us happy
so we could make smarter decisions about our
futures when we got back.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah. I mean we-we feel like
the path to adulthood is-is no longer as linear
as it used to be like as our moms' generation
you tended to go to college, get married,
have kids. And we have all these amazing choices
and all these things that we can do which
is just incredible, but I think for us, we
just wanted to take some time out and be really
mindful about like what we were doing.
So for this, for the year that we went abroad
we got to live out our real life bucket list.
We got to hike the Inca trail in Peru and
take surf lessons in Australia, and volunteer
in Kenya.
And I think like the biggest, one of the biggest
things that we learned is that in New York
we felt like time was just speeding, speeding,
speeding by and when we were on the road it
was the longest year of our lives in the best
way possible. Time just seemed to really slow
down and-and become bigger. And I think it's
because we were living really mindfully and
everything was new so we felt like we were
a lot more present.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah, and I think one of
the things that people ask of us and things
we expected from ourselves from this trip
is that if we took this year off we'd better
have some huge epiphanies about our lives
and-and figure things out, and that maybe
somehow we'd be different by the end of it.
But as we learned, taking this trip and going
to these different countries and meeting a
million different people that the questions
that you have for yourself and the answers
that you expect to get from traveling are
really never the ones that you ask.
And if we could go back and talk to ourselves
when we were in our mid to late 20's and stressing
about our futures, we-we might have told them
that eventually you kind of realize not to
sweat the small stuff which is what we learned
on the trip.
But I think if we'd, if we'd known that and
really accepted that, we might never have
gone away and we wouldn't have traded our
trip around the world for anything.
So we're really happy to be here to be sharing
the experience with you and hopefully the
fact that you're here in the room means that
you on some level are interested in traveling
and maybe even if it's just for a short period
of time.
So we'd love to answer your questions today
and answer Lee's questions about the trip.
>>Lee: Yeah, I mean you-you mentioned Amanda
that you met Holly at-at work. How did you
meet Jennifer, like how did you guys realize
you had this common like frustration and then
come up with the solution?
>>Holly Corbett: It's funny. I didn't even
know Jenn before we took the vacation to Argentina.
I think Amanda and I were in the office and
it was nine o'clock at night and she said
that she was gonna take this trip with her-her
roommate, Jenn, and she knew Jenn from college.
And she asked if I wanted to go and-and I
said, "Yes."
And I charged the plane ticket and I think
they were kinda surprised, but that's-that's
how it all started.
So --
>>Amanda Pressner: We were that desperate
to get away. [laughs]
>>Holly Corbett: [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: We were --
>>Holly Corbett: We were like --
>>Amanda Pressner: really excited. Yeah.
>>Holly Corbett: So, yeah I didn't even know
Jenn before the trip. But we slept head to
toe for a year so now we know each other really
well.
>>Lee: I guess the bonding period was more
after the trip and it more just like you made
the decisions independently and then went
on the trip together and that's what --
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Lee: really kind of found like this common
thread.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Lee: Well and if anybody at any point, grab
a microphone, just jump up, pull it off the
stand or you can stand at it either way if
you have a question feel free. Don't be shy.
Well I guess tell me about I don't know, I've-I've-I've
traveled a lot myself, but I've al-, I've
always traveled by myself so I-I feel like
it's in one way forces you to engage in the
culture as well.
Tell me about how you guys kind of reached
outside of yourselves as a group and engaged
in the culture, and give me maybe a couple
of different examples of some places.
>>Amanda Pressner: Well Jenn unfortunately
is not here, but it was always her dream to
volunteer in Kenya.
I think for me like I could barely just wrap
my brain around the fact that we were leaving
to travel for so long. And fortunately Jenn
and Holly actually had some really amazing
ideas of things that we could do.
Holly wanted to go to an ashram and learn
to meditate and-and learn how to challenge,
I don't know challenge herself in that way.
Jenn wanted --
>>Holly Corbett: Quiet my mind.
>>Amanda Pressner: yeah-yeah quiet our minds
a little bit.
But the volunteer experience which was a month
for us; we went to a farm in rural Southwestern
Kenya and we showed up thinking, "Okay we've
signed up for this volunteer program. Great,
give us some work to do. Give us some shovels
and give us something."
And the volunteer coordinator who was a local
Kenyan was like, "Ah, there's no work today;
maybe tomorrow." And that happened the next
day and the next day.
We were baffled like, "What-what are we supposed
to do?" And we went into the school and there
were already teachers teaching English. So
we really had to challenge ourselves at that
point to find a way to contribute to this
community.
And we were on the grounds of a school, but
we learned when we got there that there were
12 preteen girls who had recently been moved
onto the grounds of this school because as
they were walking there every day to go to
class, they were being attacked by local men
who in some cases had committed acts of violence
against them.
And so we realized that these young women
didn't have anybody really to talk to. They
didn't have any mentors; there weren't counselors.
'Cause it really wasn't supposed to be a home
and we decided every day to start working
with them and kind of drawing them out of
their shells and playing games with them.
And eventually we started doing dance classes
with them because that's a background that
I've had.
And eventually we wrote a play with them called
The Tree Grows in Kenya and [laughs]
>>Lee: [chuckles]
>>Amanda Pressner: and that was kind of a
legacy we left with them.
And by the time we-we said good bye at the
end of the month, we were all crying because
we'd developed this tremendous bond with these
young women. And all of them, we'd seen them
blossom and-and feel stronger and safer and
that has forever changed the three of us.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah. I-I think the places
where we stayed the longest were the places
where we had the best memories.
And that was probably in Kenya or in Peru
we stayed for awhile. We lived with Amanda's
friend in Australia for awhile.
So that was nice; we really got to know the
places, but I think it's different when you
travel by yourself.
>>Lee: Hum.
>>Holly Corbett: I think people approach you
more because you're alone 'cause compared
to three of us could be kind of intimating.
So I think when you travel with other people
you kind of have to make more of an effort
to put yourself out there ?
>>Lee: Sure.
>>Holly Corbett: and-and talk to people.
>>Lee: So tell me about when like-like it
sounds like it started off as trip, when-when
did the, when did the blog come in? When did
the idea for the writing the book together
come into play, and how did that come into
like the website you guys have now?
>>Holly Corbett: Well, when we first took
off for the trip, Amanda is like our Web guru
and she-she really wanted to keep in touch.
And originally we started the blog to kinda
keep in touch with our friends and our-our
family back home, and that's kinda how that
happened.
But the blog kinda, Amanda can talk more about
this, but it kinda took on a life of its own
because at first it was about us and our trip,
but when we came back there were so many other
people saying, "Hey, I'm a lost girl or I'm
a lost boy. I wanna travel too," or "I've
traveled. Can I share my story?"
So it kind of became -- it's not really about
us but other people who really just wanna
share their stories.
And from the blog, that's how the book came
about. Because a publishing company saw ?
>>Lee: Oh.
>>Holly Corbett: the blog and then asked us
to do a proposal and --
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah, I-I wanna add that
I'm not a Web guru compared to anybody in
this room, but [laughs] --
>>Holly Corbett: [laughs] We're at Google.
>>Amanda Pressner: [laughs] Yeah. Yeah, but
I want, right when we were planning to take
the trip it was the time we're blogging and
that platform had kind of just become the
thing like where normal everyday citizens
could do it.
And I knew that I wanted to have a way of
keeping in touch with-with friends and family
and colleagues and letting them know what
we were doing and this just seemed like a
really easy way to do it.
It was a challenge trying to keep it up as
we were traveling though 'cause we were in
countries where there was slow Internet, no
Internet.
I remember going in Myanmar which was Burma
and getting to that country with Holly and
Holly coming out of her room somewhere being
like, "Oh there's no Internet here." And I
was like, "Oh you mean at this hotel? Well
let's just go find-find an Internet cafe."
She's like, "No, in the, in the country."
[laughs]
>>Holly Corbett: [laughs]
>>Lee: [laughs)
]
>>Amanda Pressner: And my jaw dropped for
like a good five seconds and then we realized
in-in Myanmar, this freedom that we have here
to exchange information is-is so restricted
that they actually have underground Internet
cafes where you go in and it's kinda like
asking for other illegal substances. We're
like, "Hey do have ?
>>Lee: [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: do you have Google --
>>Amanda Pressner: do you --
>>Holly Corbett: [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: have Hotmail? And-and they'll
hook you up if you pay them [laughs] some
money so --
>>Lee: [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: We eventually somehow kept
out blog going and we try-try to give ourselves
the goal of posting once a week each one of
us.
And like Holly said when we got back we had
this moment of like, "Do we keep this website
going when we're not actually traveling?"
But now at this point it has become such an
online portal for other young travelers who
either want information, I mean Holly and
I come from a magazine background so we wanna
bring as much service to it as we can, but
just knowing that other, there are hundreds,
thousands of other young people out there
who have taken a risk, who've left their jobs
to travel; have traveled after school; and
who wanna make it a part of their lives.
We felt like we kind of just had to turn this
over to them and keep it going.
>>Lee: You bring up an interesting point about
traveling or leaving your job to travel or
traveling after school, so kind of a two-part
question about I guess the-the money behind
traveling or saving or do you think it's in
your experience wise to travel after school
or to start your career or do you think it's
different to, unique to the individual or?
>>Amanda Pressner: Want me to answer that?
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah, I think, I think
we've kind of determined that there are few
times in your life where maybe it makes more
sense to travel. If you are reading the papers
these days, going online, you'll see that
there's a big popularity for a gap year which
technically is the year between high school
and college that people in other countries
in the UK and Europe, that's a time where
young people will travel.
Here in this country we do study abroad. Sometimes
people travel after college, but it kind of
gets sticky once you're in the working world.
You're like, "Well when do I leave? Am I gonna
commit career suicide if I, if I travel? What
will my bosses think? I'll have this hole
in my resume."
But we've found and we've had now several
other friends who've left to travel and I'm
not necessarily encouraging that 'cause Google's
such a great place to work from what I heard.
But that it's really not -- you do not sacrifice
everything else in your resume when you decide
to leave to travel.
The-the experience that we had when we came
back in was that people were really impressed
that we'd taken such a risk and we volunteered
when we were away; we worked while we were
away; and we were able to build other skills.
So I really think that now if travel's something
that's important to you, you can absolutely
find a way to make it work.
We do think it's a good idea to have a few
years of work experience like two or three
at least so that you can come back and say,
"I've been in the working world and I wanna
come back."
>>Lee: Wanna come back.
Risk taking I think is something we value
here. It may be painful for your manager probably
in the meantime to figure out for someone
to deal with the workload, but ultimately
they are like, "Oh wow, like I wish I could
do that or have the strength to do that."
Which is I think is very commendable.
In fact ?
>>Amanda Pressner: [chuckles]
>>Lee: I think I'm gonna go catch a plane
and I'm gonna get out of here.
>>Holly Corbett: [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: [laughs]
>>Lee: [laughs]
I feel like I need a, need a, need to get
out of this office every once in awhile.
>>Holly Corbett: [laughs]
>>Lee: We probably all feel like that.
So I mean I guess with, let's say we don't
wanna leave our jobs or we don't have the
opportunity to travel for-for several months
and let's say we have to deal with our normal
vacation period, three or, three weeks or
four weeks. Do you feel like -- how do you
best maximize your time even though you're
still trying to find that balance or maybe
working up towards a longer trip?
>>Holly Corbett: Well I think you don't have
to do something as drastic as we did and quit
your jobs and backpack around the world for
a year. I think one of the things that we
brought back from our trip is how to kinda
get lost doing the things we love in our everyday
life. And-and we realize that a lot of the
pressure that we were putting on ourselves
to achieve and-and --
>>Lee: Uh-hum.
>>Holly Corbett: get promotions and putting
all our energy into the work wasn't coming
from our bosses or our friends or our parents.
It was coming from ourselves. And it took
us to take that trip in order to realize we
have to make fun a priority; we have to make
following our passions a priority.
So I think for people who have two weeks'
vacation if they can get away for two weeks,
maybe kind of volunteer somewhere to get a
different perspective or go to cooking school
if that's something that you've wanted, wanna
be doing.
I think that rather than just vegging out
'cause a lot of times we do need it 'cause
we're working so hard, but it's good to use
our time off to kind of dabble in other things
that we're interested in. And I think ?
>>Lee: Um-hum.
>>Holly Corbett: that's how you get the most
out of your time off.
>>Lee: Yeah. That's true.
>>Amanda Pressner: And I would add not to
be afraid to travel by yourself. I think that
that's really a time where you learn so much
about yourself and you-you challenge yourself
in a way that you might not do here when you
have your friends and family around you.
So if you have a week, do something structured;
volunteer, go to language school, or cooking
school as Holly --
>>Lee: Um-hum.
>>Amanda Pressner: suggested. And just go.
>>Lee: Yeah.
>>female in audience: Can you describe the
moment when you told your friends, colleagues,
and boyfriends that you were leaving? Like
[chuckles] if we were a fly on the wall [laughs]
--
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah. A lot of, lot of
people were shocked, but there was no -- I
was really expecting people to be like, "What
the hell are you doing? Like you are crazy
for leaving everything."
But it, people really, there was some shock
and then people were like, "Oh my God, that's
so cool. Like can I come? Can I carry your
bag?" Like people wanted to go. So --
>>Holly Corbett: I was terrified to tell my
boss. I remember it was a Friday and I walked
in the office, I had like everything I was
gonna say prepared and I waited all day because
I loved my boss. She was like my mentor and
I didn't wanna disappoint her and I waited
all day and finally at like 5:39, I knew she
was gonna be leaving soon. I ran into her
office. And I was like, "Stephanie, I have
something to tell you." And she's like, "Oh
my God. You're leaving us." And I'm like,
"Yes." She's like, "Where are you going? What
magazine?" I said, "It's not for another magazine.
I'm-I'm leaving to travel the world." And
she kind of looked at me like, "What?" I'm
like, "Yes, I'm-I'm gonna take off with two
of my friends and-and I'm gonna travel for
a year. I've decided that I'm not married,
I don't have kids, it's now or never. I might
as well. I'll always regret it if I don't
do it."
So they were amazingly supportive. Like my
boss was so supportive. They even helped me
write while I was on the road and-and gave
me a column in an online magazine or a smaller
magazine which actually went under three months
later like a lot of --
>>Lee: [laughs]
>>Holly Corbett: victims in publishing.
But yeah, people were very supportive. Friends
and family; our parents kind of thought we
were nuts, but --
>>Amanda Pressner: Boyfriends had more --
>>Holly Corbett: they went with it.
>>Amanda Pressner: trouble with it but --
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah, boyfriends were --
>>Amanda Pressner: They were like, "Oh great."
[laughs]
>>Lee: [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Lee: Oh.
[pause]
>>female in audience: I'm cur, oh. Hi, I'm
curious how you guys approached writing in
a collaborative way 'cause it seems like you
would have had, even though you were traveling
together, you would have had such individual
experiences as you were traveling --
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>female in audience: so having not read the
book yet, how did you actually approach that?
>>Amanda Pressner: I'd say that the blog actually
really helped with that. I think it was really
inadvertent, but the way the blog got written
is if something happened in our lives that
was really compelling we're like, "Oh my God,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna put something on the
blog about that."
So when like the time came to write the book
we already had this online record of things
that were really meaningful to us and we sat
down once the book, we'd written the book
proposal. We tried to, we tried to outline
it and story board it, and the biggest issue
we had was really just figuring out out of
all these millions and millions of memories
of what was important enough to include.
I mean it's a pretty significantly [laughs]
thick book. So --
>>Holly Corbett: We put a lot --
>>Amanda Pressner: we didn't do that great
of a job narrowing it down, but yeah we all
decided. There really was very little like,
"Oh no, I wanna write that chapter."
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: We all kind of agreed.
>>Holly Corbett: I-I think that too, we didn't
do a lot of journaling. I know when I travel
alone I compulsively journal. I'll, I will
sit there and write everything down, but because
we were traveling with-with three of us all
together we would talk a lot. So it was nice
that we had a collective memory. Whenever
I couldn't remember something, I would call
Jenn or Amanda.
But I think we had been traveling together
for so long, I had never in my life spent
so much time with two other people. I mean
everything from waking up to where are we
going to breakfast to what are we doing today?
I mean we-we tended to all sleep in the same
room; sometimes in the same bed because we
wanted to stretch out our budget. And I think
that really helped in the collaborative book
process because we were so used to how each
other thought and how we communicated that
it was really easy to divide up the book and
the story line.
>>Lee: And you like-like --
>>female in audience: Did you write it in
one voice?
>>Holly Corbett: No, three different voices.
We kind of played off each other. It's kind
of like sometimes I say like a Jodi Picoult
novel where it's the same story told from
a lot of different perspectives.
So it's the three of our perspectives, but
we take different sections or different things
that happened along the way.
>>Amanda Pressnber: It would be, you would
think it would be confusing but a lot, and
we were worried about that, but people who
read the book have said, "I was, I had to
look down to see which one of you was writing,"
'cause our tone like really became very similar
as the writing continued.
But -- so I think it was seamless, hopefully
in that way, but completely different characters.
>>Lee: Any like serious points of friction
while you guys were traveling like being so
close were there moments, were there any like
big fights or --
>>Holly Corbett: Of course there were. [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: [laughs]
>>Lee: Did it have a productive outcome or
were they just like getting through and-and
coming up with a compromise?
>>Holly Corbett: I think --
>>Lee: Or was it just tensions were high and
you were just in a bad mood?
>>Amanda Pressner: Want me to answer that?
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah. I mean I think the
biggest point of tension was I was like the
most adamant about going and leaving work
and I had the most trouble of the three of
us of actually doing that once we hit the
road. Like I had my laptop with me, I want,
I had the blog and then I was also like, "Oh
this is a great chance for me to freelance
write and be a travel writer." And I just
couldn't let go of it.
And Jenn, who's not here unfortunately to
share her point of view, is much more of a
travel purist. She-she was saying, "Well we've
quit our jobs, we've left our lives, like
if we're gonna do this year around the world,
let's do it. Let's immerse ourselves in the
culture. Let's not put any filters between
us and the places that we're visiting."
And for she and I that caused a lot of tension.
I mean Holly tended to be the peacemaker between
us 'cause she could see both of our perspectives
being a fellow journalist, but also being
a-a traveler and-and seeing both sides.
So I think other than that though we really
were able to -- I think there were no divas
in our group so we really focused on the good
of the whole, the good of the group. And really
in that way learned to be very unselfish and
to be very in tune to, "Holly seems like she
might be a little space today. Let's let her
have like the morning by herself, and come
back." We weren't perfect but we really did
learn to read each other's signs. And in some
ways it was like a marriage, like you really
put the good of the whole versus the good,
the good of you. And --
>>Lee: Um-hum.
>>Amanda Pressner: that's how we survived.
[chuckles]
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Holly Corbett: Defintely.
I --
>>Lee: Any stories come to mind?
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah. I'm trying to think,
I think that it was, it was like a lot about,
a lot about compromise and just really learning
how to compromise. And the beauty is that
we had three people. So if you wanted some
alone time, you didn't feel like you were
leaving the other person by themselves.
>>Lee: Right.
>>Holly Corbett: So it was, three was a good
number for us.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Lee: Yeah. It sounds like it; sounds like
it's a good combination.
And I guess recently the rights were picked
up for, by Jerry Bruckheimer for make, turning
this into a-a television series on ABC? Is
that, is that true?
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Lee: What do you guys think, or what, I
mean I'm sure that's an interesting process
to turn I guess any-any literary work into
a television series. But how do you see that
or how-how would you manifest it?
>>Amanda Pressner: Well I'm, obviously we're
hugely excited. Kind of couldn't believe it
at first that somebody like Jerry Bruckheimer,
who's been in the business forever would be
interested in this story.
But I, we-we did think like, "Wow! This really
must mean that the sea change is upon us."
And-and travel and hopefully stories led by
strong women -- that it will be fictionalized.
It's not gonna be us on TV, thank God. They
will, they have hired a writer now to create
the pilot for this.
So it's not a hundred percent of a guarantee
that it'll air, but they already know the
first country that they're gonna be shooting
in and we're-we're --
>>Lee: Which is?
>>Amanda Pressner: kind of overwhelmed.
>>Holly Corbett: Australia?
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah, yeah I be, we think
it's Australia. So --
>>Holly Corbett: It's really cool because
Jerry Bruckheimer does like The Amazing Race.
So they have production companies --
>>Lee: Right.
>>Holly Corbett: around the world. So it'll
probably be set in a lot of different countries
as opposed to ?
>>Lee: Right.
>>Holly Corbett: just filmed in the States.
>>Lee: Yeah it seems like a good, to leverage
those resources and do little small things
different places.
>>Holly Corbett: It'll be exciting to see,
but it'll be very fictionalized so --
>>Lee: Of course.
>>Amanda Pressner: [laughs]
>>Holly Corbett: It'll be much more adventurous
than we were.
>>Amanda Pressner: [laughs] We might even
look very different than we did in the book.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Lee: [laughs] Naturally.
Any other questions from anyone?
>>male in audience: So this is a pretty vague
question, but I think you probably know how
to answer it. Do you still consider yourselves
lost?
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Holly Corbett: [laughs]
>>Lee: [laughs]
>>Amanda Pressner: But we, I think we learned
by the end of our journey that the point really
wasn't to escape being lost or to be found,
but it was really to embrace the idea of being
lost, and that, really that feeling that you
have of not knowing a hundred percent where
your life is going is a really positive one.
That it means that you are capable of growing
and changing. And-and you're gonna start seeking
outside of yourself to find ways to-to grow
and so that's what we tell people is like
not to run away from-from that feeling but
to-to embrace it.
>>Holly Corbett: And I think what-what I learned
during the trip is that a lot of times I was
upset at myself for being restless and actually
I think it's a great thing. It's-it's a great
thing to have that sense of, "Okay I don't
know what my future's gonna hold, but I am
gonna live more mindfully; I am going to make
time for the things that matter to me." So
--
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah. Just to dwell on
it --
>>Holly Corbett: We don't wanna get unlost.
We like it.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah. Just to be more comfortable
with it 'cause one-once you start welcoming
that feeling and-and knowing that it's gonna
come during periods in your life it's not-not
nearly as scary.
[pause]
>>Lee: So what's next for you guys? I'm sorry,
go ahead. Go ahead.
>>female in audience: That's okay actually
I'm curious about that question too.
But I was just wondering on your travels and
I've travelled a lot too and I love traveling,
so your story is very like inspiring to me.
But was there any specific place that you
guys were individually where you said to yourself,
"Oh, I could come back and live here?"
Or like, "I'm so glad I did this trip because
I can totally see myself coming back here
again," or something like that?
>>Holly Corbett: My gosh, there were so many
amazing places. I think I never knew how beautiful
the world was until we got off the plane in
New Zealand. It really was like Lord of the
Rings territory with the-the mountains and
everything.
So I really I loved New Zealand.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah, I-I got a chance
to go to Laos which Holly unfortunately was
in a different place --
>>Holly Corbett: I was still in India in the
ashram. That was the only time that we split
up during the year.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Holly Corbett: I stayed for a teacher training
for yoga and they went to Laos.
>>Amanda Pressner: There's so much of Southeast
Asia, it's an amaz - , if you guys are ever
considering taking some time out to travel.
It's an amazing region to travel to for so
many reasons.
At first it's so culturally rich and you really
feel like you're traveling. You're not on
vacation when you're, when you're there. And
it's also really affordable economically.
Like once you get on the plane and arrive
there.
I-I love Lao, they say Lao in-in the local
country 'cause it's French or Laos here, because
they just opened it up to tourism not that
long ago and I feel like in other parts of
Southeast Asia that are more touristed, you
kind of lose that sense of authenticity.
But when I was there it's a beautiful country,
the people are very genteel and welcoming,
and I really felt like I got an opportunity
to immerse myself in that culture almost more
than anywhere else that I went. So I'd love
to go back.
>>Holly Corbett: And we actually realized
we didn't tell you exactly where we went.
We-we left Europe out of it because we wanted
to travel on about 30 dollars a day and like
Africa, Southeast Asia, South America were
a lot cheaper.
So we started out; we left New York; we went
to Peru, Bolivia, Brazil, Kenya, India. Then
we kind of hop scotched around Southeast Asia;
went to Bali, New Zealand, Australia, which
ate up --
>>Amanda Pressner: All the rest of our money.
>>Holly Corbett: any remaining budget and
came back home.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
[pause]
>>Lee: Any other questions?
Yeah.
>>female in audience: I'm curious what your
reentry process was like. A, what you are
doing now and B, how quickly if you guys are
back in the corporate world, how quickly you
got wrapped up in the rat race again?
>>Holly Corbett: Oh we learned that just because
we come back, the same stresses and the same
pressures that we left behind were still there,
but how we reacted to them was very different.
I think travel made us a lot more resilient
and-and we -- maybe a little bit more braver
because surprisingly when we came back we
actually had more job offers then even before
we left which really surprised us 'cause we
thought that we might have looked like slackers
for kind of taking off and vagabonding.
But actually people were really our bosses
and-and people in the industry were really
supportive.
But rather than take a full time desk job
like we normally probably would have, at least
for me I stayed free lance which is again
not very safe. There's not the steady income
but it was something that allowed me to still
be working, generating income, be creative,
but have more time for the other things that
I, that I love doing. So --
>>Amanda Pressner: I was fortunate I'd kept
up with some contacts that I'd been freelancing
for before I left and got an offer about six
weeks after coming home for a much higher
level position.
I was the senior nutrition editor at Shape
Magazine and it was a job that I felt like
I couldn't turn down. Like I had the urge
to just freelance like Holly to slow that
transition, but I'd been an assistant before
and like it's too big of a jump, it's too
good of an offer not to do. And so I definitely
struggled sitting back at the desk.
I remember like Holly had said, our year was
so long because it was so rich with experiences,
and I would get really forlorn those first
few months when I was still at the office
at nine o'clock thinking, "Oh my God, an entire
day of my life has gone by and I haven't experienced
it. I've been staring at my computer screen
all day."
So I think what the trip did for me was it
made me less afraid to go in and address that
issue with my boss. I think we're all really
afraid sometimes of we don't wanna look like
the person who doesn't wanna work hard.
But I-I was able to address that. I was able
to make some changes and was able to go three
days a week at the magazine which was kind
of unusual.
But I think because I'd had this trip experience
my editor-in-chief knew that I kinda meant
business and that if I wasn't happy I wasn't
gonna force myself to stay. I was gonna find
a job situation that worked better.
It's not always possible, but I think we've
all kind of taken that commitment to really
living our lives in the moment as much as
possible like through to this day. So --
>>Lee: It seems like the confidence is certainly
?
[pause]
I mean it certainly has its, I mean I don't
know, I mean you could, it's effective in
the workplace to be, to be respected and to
be, to have that kind of strength. I don't
know it just kind of --
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah, I think it's just you
don't have to be so afraid to ask for what
you want and I think before, we were more
intimidated about asking for what we wanted.
And-and if you don't ask, you're not gonna
get it. And sometimes when you do ask you're
not gonna get it, but I think you feel better
about yourself because you-you tried.
>>Lee: Um-hum.
>>Holly Corbett: And I think that-that's kind
of the approach we took when we came back
from the trip.
>>Lee: Any other questions? I think we have
time for one more perhaps.
[pause]
>>female in audience: I'm curious to know
how often you travel now. Have you found that
you have an even longer list of places you
wanna visit or you think, "Ah, I've seen a
lot. Maybe I'll take it easy and not leave
as often?"
>>Holly Corbett: I think it's funny 'cause
you think the more places you travel the shorter
your travel wish list is gonna get, but it
just keeps getting longer the more places
you wanna go. Or the more places you go, the
more places you wanna see.
And we made a pact, the three of us, to take
a trip together once a year every year for
the rest of our lives.
So we've been doing that. We just went to
Napa. So we're trying to do more places in
the States. And last year we went to Panama.
But yeah, we try to, we try to travel whenever
we can. But we don't feel that desperate need
for a break like we used to because I think
we've learned to just better balance our lives.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah, it is still hard.
I-I think definitely one thing we learned
from this is you-you don't come home and all
your problems are solved and you suddenly
have vacation time galore. Like it is really
hard to still find the time to travel and
we'll do, we'll do a lot of weekend stuff.
But getting the three of us to find one week
that works for everybody is-is still really
difficult.
It has to be a priority which is why we set
that-that goal of-of traveling together once
a year.
I think we really wanna go to the Philippines
next.
>>Holly Corbett: Yes.
>>Amanda Pressner: That's, we wanna scuba
dive.
>>Lee: [laughs]
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah. Tickets are expensive
in December, though; seventeen hundred dollars
so we have to find a cheaper time --
>>Amanda Pressner: Find a cheaper time to
go.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Lee: So are you guys working on any projects
together? What's next for you guys?
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah, we're actually well
we're working on a second book, "How to Get
Lost", which is gonna be more of a guide like
how to budget, how to save.
And also we're-we're working on kind of like
a philanthropy part of the site. We are starting
to organize Lost Girls races across the country.
So ?
>>Lee: Um-hum.
>>Holly Corbett: we're still in the process
of figuring it out, but we're trying to raise
money to send nurses to school in Kenya because
we volunteered through Village Volunteers
in Kenya so.
>>Lee: Um-hum.
>>Holly Corbett: We just kinda wanna get other
lost girls and boys together across the country
and kinda networking and-and working together
for a healthy goal like a race and to use
the money from the races to kind of send other
women to school to help them achieve their
dreams.
>>Lee: That's really cool.
Anybody, one more question perhaps? We got
a couple of minutes.
Yes.
[pause]
>>female in audience: [inaudible] How long
did it take to write the book?
>>Holly Corbett: So --
>>Lee: The question is how long, how long
did it take you to write the book?
>>Holly Corbett: We didn't write it straight
through. We kinda tend to procrastinate. So
--
>>Amanda Pressner: [laughs]
>>Holly Corbett: I think we had for the first
draft a year to write it and I think we waited
until nine months and we kinda, is that right,
crammed it --
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah, well it was hard
because we were all working again and writing
a book is a lot more of an intensive process
than I think even I realized.
So that was part of the reason I went three
days a week at Shape was I'm like, "The book
will never get written if I don't start reprioritizing."
So we started writing it really intensively
in August and got an extension and turned
it in like at the end of March?
>>Holly Corbett: Um-hum.
>>Amanda Pressner: So it was probably about
eight months if I'm doing the math correctly.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah. And we-we, it took
us a long time I think 'cause we were used
to magazine writing which is very different
from memoir writing and none of the three
of us really knew what we were doing in the
beginning. So I think they say you have to
write a hundred pages to find your voice and
I think I definitely wrote a hundred pages
and --
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Holly Corbett: threw 'em away before we
got the first draft kind of done.
>>Lee: So obviously being in publishing in-in
magazines what did you kind of think the future
of publishing is going to be?
>>Holly Corbett: Oh my gosh!!
>>Amanda Pressner: Wow!
>>Holly Corbett: If we knew the answer to
that question --
>>Lee: [laughs]
I had to ask. I had to ask.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah, I-I-I don't know as
far as like magazines going on -- online and-and
things like that.
>>Amanda Pressner: I would say that I think
we're in this experimental period with publishing.
I don't ever think that print magazines will
entirely go away. I think that there is a
tremendous amount of blogs and websites and
Twitter and-and so much information online
and I think it's just an expansion period
and testing.
And-and it will narrow back out again as it
doesn't become financially viable for writers
to make one cent a word to write ?
>>Lee: Right.
>>Amanda Pressner: for a website. But I don't
think blogging will ever go away. I think
people will always wanna express themselves
online. And if 10 people are reading that
might be fine for-for somebody.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Lee: It's gonna get, I guess I mean 'cause
you guys were, I mean the book deal came out
of the blog originally, right?
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Lee: So it's been a way to kind of help
vet ideas and --
>>Amanda Pressner: Absolutely.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: Like we learned what worked
and didn't work a lot really early on, I think
from having the blog. When we started the
blog we wrote as a we voice like we didn't
individualize ourselves and people were like,
"What is this?" Like, "Who's talking?"
>>Holly Corbett: Who's talking?
>>Amanda Pressner: So we-we learned to, that
it was okay for there to be three writers
-
>>Lee: Right.
>>Amanda Pressner: And we learned things that
were really controversial.
There's a chapter where we write about prostitution
in one of the countries that we visited and-and
we really were only in this area for a few
days. And writing about it when I wrote about
it on the blog, people just, the comments
were horrible because here I was this outsider
coming in and making social commentary about
a livelihood of a young woman in-in Thailand
and it-it really made me, it really opened
my eyes and made me think, "Okay, before I
write about something like this in the book
I really wanna do some research." And in that
way I think it helped me to be a better writer
having a blog.
>>Lee: Yeah.
Well thank you very much for coming.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
>>Amanda Pressner: Yeah.
>>Lee: It was very, very interesting and I
think we gave some books to some, and they'll
be willing to sign them if you wanna come
up afterwards.
>>Holly Corbett: Yeah.
Thank you guys so much for coming.
>>Amanda Pressner: Thank you for coming.
>>Lee: Thanks Amanda and Holly.
[applause]